and your mom was watching just regular
news and the commentator was saying
something negative about our president
and what was her reaction she says poor
guy they're going to kill him tomorrow
because that's normal in Iran you don't
talk against uh uh you know presidents
that's just not something you do in Iran
you don't do that in America it's normal
in America it's a business model like
we're doing it today last two hours this
is what we've been doing I'd be homeless
yeah otherwise you wouldn't be homeless
maybe five of us outside today so it's
like hey Rob's gonna say look I'm just
working here man I wasn't doing anything
I'm just having my drink and enjoying it
but it'd be me Adam Rob and Tom uh
outside of item in a statement being
made talk about us one more time that
would be the case in Iran okay